Cantus Taeyang Becca says that in the
past French automaker said when produced
legendary models like the de s and the
douche evolve
but recently unusual and innovative cars
like these have been missing from its
model range the c4 cactus seems to
change that it's novel approach sets it
apart from its competitors is this the
next French Revolution John says it's
when calls these air-filled side panels
air bumps they protect the paint job
from getting scratched or dented while
parking or out shopping saving you money
on pricey touch-up jobs and repairs Yan
says saving is one of the c4 cactuses
major concepts on weight as well as
money
the base model cactus has a curb weight
of just one thousand forty kilos two
hundred less than the Citroen c4 compact
to shed weight the car makers engineers
trimmed down the platform and did
without some extra equipment the c4
cactus has a starting price of just
under fourteen thousand euros though our
test car with a 60 kilowatt engine sells
for around sixteen thousand five hundred
the cactuses rounded front features
modern LED daytime running lights above
the halogen headlights dirty air bumps
on the sides and two at the front and
back provide protection from dings and
scratches cetanas also replaced
traditional winddown rear windows with
pop-out ones that alone makes the car 11
kilos lighter the rear seat bench only
folds down in one piece which sits when
claimed saves another 6 kilos God says
that for its relatively small price you
can't expect real leather upholstery but
he feels sin has managed to give the
cactuses interior a high-quality feel
mainly through the use of different
surface materials he says everything's
very minimalist and focused on what's
important he especially likes the
luggage strap door handles together with
the aluminum door openers Andy approves
of the glove compartment design which
resembles suitcases of the 1960s and 70s
to make space for that large and [ __ ]
glove compartment the front passenger
air bag has been moved and is now
elegantly stowed in the roof
Yan says the two modern displays at the
front contrasts nicely with the retro
luggage look though the first display
only tells him his speed and how much
gas he has in the tank
there's no tachometer for instance but
he can't control all of the other
functions over the touchscreen like the
sat-nav or the climate control yan says
it all works really well though he'd
like the system to react a bit quicker
as he has to control almost every
function by a touchscreen Citroen has
found ways of saving on cost weight and
resources on even the most banal
equipment like the windshield washer
system called magic wash its washer Jets
are fitted in the tips of the wipers to
provide a bead of liquid rather than a
spray so there's no loss of visibility
when washing the system saves on window
washer fluid too so the fluid reservoir
can be smaller and therefore lighter
from fine but how does the c4 cactus
Drive John finds the steering very
smooth and the suspension quite soft so
you barely notice when you go over bumpy
roads though the suspension is a bit too
soft for his taste and like the do
cheveux before it he says the cactus
tends to shudder a bit when starting and
braking so maybe it's not the automotive
revolution we've been waiting for that's
undergone fields what's really special
about the c4 cactus is that citron has
built a back-to-basics car it has few
bells and whistles but doesn't scrimp on
comfort either it's packaged in a fresh
design at an affordable price so the
cactus c4 could be called a mini
revolution after all